hey what's up party people welcome to
the honest trailer commentary for Snow
White and Huntsman Huntsman winters or
Spencer Thank You line
look if you're watching this video
you're a true fan it's not your first
commentary I promise you know how this
works or you've got here by mistake
in which case I'm sorry cuz we're about
to talk about the Huntsman's the plural
and and do some deleted scenes and talk
to you via your comments T's next week's
episode we talk about anything I'll spin
these movies
I know before we went live this movie we
could just talk about Lord of the Rings
these films exist they exist because I
guess the Alice in Wonderland movie was
a big hit around that time or two years
beforehand as was Lord of the Rings and
they said give me one of those and they
gave it to us and we had it and it's
gone there was this era where like
fairytale adaptations were giants why
that's baffling yeah we still haven't
quite escaped that era weirdly know
there was Mirror Mirror
yeah something I've pitched for a long
time that has never really gained
traction but maybe someone out there
will make it is the public domain
Avengers movie well you did make that it
was the Avengers it was likely because
it was ordinary General Robin Hood
okay all the cheap characters we can
just use this everyone yeah but together
yeah so if you out there have a take on
a fairy tale I guess you can just go
sell a movie based on it obviously this
has always sort of been like a thing
like we've won like in the nineties a
nice new script coverage there was
always like it's a modern take on Peter
Pan like a letter especially earlier
younger writers starting out that's like
a thing you can do is take this really
well-established story and like twist
your own spin on it and weirdly though
Disney's been able to conquer the world
based on doing the same thing right
yeah like are we allowed to just make a
family-friendly animated Peter Pan movie
it just really said yeah yeah alright
like Robin Hood is a good example like
every year there's a new what if you
forgot what you thought you knew Robin
Hood as a sexy Fox movie and I don't
think these movies can we be seen Ernest
goes to camp and if you're watching this
you haven't goes to camp yeah they have
this machine where you just like put in
whatever food you can find like a head
of lettuce and some eggs and whatever
and then it just like shoots it out like
gonna put just a ball of slime yeah
that's what these movies felt like it
was like somebody fed ten years of
movies into a machine and then it just
vomited out yeah these two completely
forgettable movies that are like
literally just made from other room I
think they put the scripts for a few
fantasy movies in there and just wrote
it on like autocomplete they're just
doing its distinctive text yeah it's
like why bother they took up a lot of
people's time yeah I don't mean the
movie goers I mean like Charlize Theron
and yeah yeah
yeah this snow in the Huntsman his last
role almost killed him during Mario
Brothers yes why bother people must have
liked the first one enough no one did
now first one viewers who was running
around saying like oh my god did you see
Snow White and the Huntsman it was great
I can't wait for another one we'd have
to look up like how the box office or
wherever but that might have been one of
those cases where it was just a movie
that was talked about so much because of
the scandal around see how they could
cut a trailer out of it like big action
romance fantasy setting like I could see
how you could pull like 45 seconds of
good looking stuff and then the Huntsman
probably had a budget of like you know
ten bucks and a ham sandwich oh no I
promise you the whole cop really stinks
to do max no that's not how Hollywood
works they double down on their mistakes
and I guess no I in the Huntsman made
150 million dollars domestically it made
four hundred million dollars worldwide
well in twenty twelve dollars that's a
billion I guess I guess so a production
budget okay the production budget of the
first one was 170 million it made four
hundred million yeah that's called
dodging a bullet yeah that's called we
just we just barely eked by and we
dodged a bullet but of course they said
no people want another one they scream
let a sequel production budget of one
hundred and fifteen million and it made
one hundred and sixty five million
worldwide which means it really felt
like they were just like what we could
do frozen live-action and everybody who
loves frozen what come cr4 it's Chris
Hemsworth right it's so deliberately
frozen esque that it feels like they
must have thought that was their magic
ticket people love angry queens
[Music]
all right let's slog through the
huntsmen why did we do this to ourselves
or to anyone sometimes it's fun to just
crap on a movie yeah yeah we had a lot
of good too many tight ropes to walk
time to just fall off let's go
six years ago go back into the archives
before you skip rattling haunts all
returned to a time when every studio was
scrambling for a franchise and Universal
Pictures wrote down the names of every
public domain fairy tale then added but
gritty to the end of something great
snow white but gritty but I mean Snow
White and the Huntsman and the Huntsman
winters war but this ain't your daddy's
Disney story because Snow White is the
colorful fairy tale and these weeks are
Grey's nightmares but that won't stop
the movie from over explaining the old
snow-white lore under explaining newer
Dumber snow white lore was this pre and
post this the first one was pre yeah the
second one I believe was post yeah yeah
I guess that's who it's for is like
Maleficent slash frozen fans cuz Snow
White I mean this audience whose table
is not teenage girls and I imagine that
this is like an Evanescence listening
like early 2000s kind of like really
it's it's it's well the first one was
personal Stewart so you're you're
looking to Bank on your Twilight that
yeah folk here you're those early
Hemsworth May 2012 so this opened like a
month after the Avengers what a summer
for Chris Hemsworth but yeah so the
first one I think you're selling right
Kristen Stewart sure Twilight etc and
then a little bit Chris Hemsworth could
but Thor would just you know he was just
crest started to crest away but then the
second one was all obviously Chris
Hemsworth yeah for you is we got we got
to work yeah we got three
we'll give them another queen to fight
to get around to a black hat I'm gonna
guess we are never gonna like it press
backspace and this is like a pre clue
we're in the middle of another very
bland forgettable let's just leave let's
just go
yeah so we're gonna we're gonna be
replaced if you weren't a hands hole
deep into the white lore and doing a
sequel full of even newer Dumberer
huntsman stuff okay we get it
magic mirrors poison apples blah blah
blah you were gonna tell us how birds
poop fairies no this is distressing for
the fandom journey to make yourself if
you're D&D crew was on xanax and me the
ASMR of fantasy casts like the Huntsman
Chris Hemsworth's
earnest combo of William Wallace Shrek
and Stewie Griffin right in new tells
why are you putting so much emphasis on
the H expressions scare tremble smile
treble and back of head treble his wife
that was in the sequel where they did
that bring croissants to be back but did
not but they just showed the back of her
characters including in the weird
post-credits scene yeah
like that they a bird or something came
and are coming back you just quit / was
fired from the spray eyes they set her
up to come back they go stood her and
she had to find out online but she would
conflicting accounts just say like
that's if this is your directing this is
one of your first big movies maybe don't
do the things that he did
she she's gotta be like they're one of
the all-time though underdog stories of
all time just seemed like they'd
completely given up on acting she's very
good when she cares right now yeah she
and our pets yeah who knew that crushing
it no they're both they're both so good
and they do such interesting work now
that it's almost like Twilight lit a
fire under them like they have to prove
themselves every time yeah like they're
just taking on only very challenging
interesting stuff because every time out
of the gate they've got like something
to prove yeah it's weird it's like it's
like there's a finite amount of career
heat and they took the hits early on but
now they're great and like Taylor
Lautner got all of it at once he did
that Adam Sandler movie and that was a
lot of direct to VOD Bruce Willis
yeah but you know we still got them good
teeth so it's huge very white teeth yeah
if you can keep the abs in teeth you'll
you'll keep getting what didn't get and
back of head Trimble his wife who's dead
was a major part of his character
development until he drops know why from
the sequel and they needed a replacement
love interest its Prince how you like
them apples and the dwarves who wait is
that a McShane though he Jones what are
you doing here this was Bob Hoskins last
role actors this good dude dwarf
faison's tiptoes his brother and like
the premise is like that's the shameful
secret that like keeps Matthew
McConaughey and his girlfriend to beef
yes be togethers that his brother is a
dwarf runs in his family and he doesn't
it's real bad as Peter Dinklage is also
in it must have been super weird and
effed up and if you think that Peter
Dinklage doesn't speak with a French
accent the project like but I do get to
do a ridiculous friend yeah yeah or that
was conditions yeah this is very I'm
gonna take this thing from the India
defends it to the French as well
Peter Dinklage incredible actor amazing
actor world-class actor on set was Gary
Oldman on his Lee's play the person you
are gonna think that tiptoes is like a
very old movie like it's very dated it
is not like not a tease oh it was a
different time I think it played at
Sundance yeah all these people were
already famous imagine Matthew
McConaughey Gary Oldman and Peter
Dinklage anyway what kind of movie they
could make but instead they made tiptoes
yeah like it's now time to like where's
our nostalgia it's only five years away
from to remove from Twitter and can you
match this cultural artifact like there
was this movie called soul man it's
really offensive but also tipped okay
the catch of its day together they'll
fight Charlize Theron who embodies the
Eddie redmayne's green whispers green
school ability the power you have wasted
on nothing but same document between us
and the frozen castle because she
couldn't let's go mm-hmm I wonder where
they got that idea or that idea she is
the one or that idea
sorry our tax man that's ID yeah he
didn't actually die mentally or that
idea or that idea so sit through two
films make a please an executive who
kept yelling make a Lord of the Rings at
his interns until it happened but we
just insult that franchises fans with
its paint-by-numbers CGI in battles bore
Game of Thrones fans with its stainless
romance irritate Harry Potter fans with
a boring joyless world of magic and
disappoint Witcher fans were not
including any coin tossing bobs
toss a coin to your Witcher do-do-do-do
oh yeah these movies are terrible and
Asgardian axe Guardian princess monotone
a bob spell Pixar's brave pards Elsa I
mean Freya Queen Freya totally different
character Honey I Shrunk the bridge Snow
White Knight and Little Nicky whack
mirror what does the mirror show you
what did you say that looks like a
golden walk on screen
don't you Liam bait me he was gonna be
another yeah yeah no it looks like a
golden walk I was gonna say something I
forgot they set up the sequel by it's
like how could we excuse having a sequel
we're after this right just give Liam
Neeson and then it like it opens with
Liam Neeson and he actually has the line
like but you didn't hear the whole story
nobody like you may think you heard the
whole story of the bad boys the second
one is it's like old fairy tales must
come to an end but not this one Prince
Charming is some of my face I can't it's
not his fault but I hear Jerry Lewis in
my head because his name is Sam Claflin
[Music]
professor Frank yes which is Jerry it's
just I guess we left some stuff for the
cutting room floor the JJ cut it's much
my stay awake for a franchise made of
one movie that took itself way too
seriously and one movie that feels like
the first one zany cousin who won't
leave your house because when you write
your star out of the sequel she takes
most of the major plot points with her
leading us to cringe at some of our best
actors struggle through some of the
worst dialog about love since well
Twilight like my own personal brand of
heroin go to music shouldn't be too hard
love conquers all rather die today you
get that paycheck thanks to oh you go
get that paycheck there was no other
reason to do this story it's supposed to
be like a play body no axe cop
Mike Huntsman oh come on guys the legend
of Bella Twilight Princess if I could
walk with the animals talk with the
animals grunt and squeak and squawk with
the animals
Charlie's Rangers rage before beauty
that girl is boys the royal bad stepmoms
made of a single ring honey Queen H
wasteland
you know nothing Jane Snow I love you
always have take my wife freeze
nice ice lady
and another one get it under blunt-force
trama technarch so white scary poppins
you're as cold as ice the Queen doesn't
take wait I know it's cold outside I
hope I hope we're all in hbo's face and
frost either no man game of Crone's the
mandatory n get ready Thor the dark
forest might takes the render a very
long time single white world's barest
Queen there all gold Jerry yeah alright
what y'all have to say about this
vanquish rights how the hell did that
movie get a sequel and Jason Burkhardt
writes wait they're both good questions
yeah
fair fair questions I guess you know you
can sell a movie more than once you know
even if it's in theaters you get to sell
it on airplanes you know then you get to
sell to a gas station TV it's also this
historical moment I mean we buy now we
we get that everybody understands that
oh yeah it's all about franchises every
studio needs all this IP that they could
turn into toys and merch and streaming
shows we're but like this was the era
when the studio's had figured that out
and so everything was just desperation
like what can we turn into a fringe the
city is full of frauds and their success
and I just want to bank on someone
else's success or just coast on a
previous successive movie makes $2 a net
they're gonna be like how because
obviously that first one like probably
barely did a probably like we got Thor
people go see tour right around Thor
this yes I said nobody obviously cared
about the sequel to that if he wasn't in
the cape with the hammer they didn't
care the Fred Durst from the fanatic
the city of bullshitters okay Isaac
Lopez Garcia how long did it take for
you guys to figure out the references to
all the other movies Danny this is real
time the princess mononoke we use the
monotony reference but that the deer
with the big is actually a different one
I had returned to the Jedi exactly so
it's nothing it almost feels like that
was the note like if they had anything
original in this the studio was like no
no no replace that surely there's a bit
from total you can steal series pooped
out of birds that was like oh Tim
Burton's Alice in Wonderland like
Bennett a few messed up shallow there's
a burning tree him there's a virgin tree
yeah no it's bereft of any originality
what's murder
Sammy rights do you have a favorite
fairy tale that you think could have a
good adaptation same as Tracy oh frights
if you had to pitch a movie reboot for a
fairy tale which would you choose and
what direction would you take it
well I think the thing is you would you
would want to pick one that was a little
bit like it still got to be known but I
think some of these just feel so warmed
over
we've heard the story so many times you
would want to maybe lean into something
a little more obscure maybe like do the
the Hans Christian Andersen like super
dark Little Mermaid what the entry dies
and turns into seafoam
yeah her feet are like yeah I do
Rumplestiltskin but it's about the folly
of the gold standard it's like that the
ABC once upon a time show right Robert
Carlyle a vessel still finds love and
makes up I don't not that Bruce Willis
is like a slide slashed my hooves no no
I don't imagine hasn't every take on a
fairy tale but we've had musical we've
had dark we've had whimsical we've had
big-budget we've had small budget we're
switching the names around now we're
going to great Gretel and Hansel now we
are now is like post the witch or the
vich whichever you prefer like now we're
doing the like oh it's creepy and might
give a glum house yeah that's the take
that's in right now yeah yeah I'm good
good like full car if I want to see Jack
in the Beanstalk I have literally every
option for how to tell that story in
front of me yeah we can imagine in like
the 30s and 40s like we kind of
Hollywood stumbled on the way to do it
which is like a big colorful animated
film like that's for children that's a
great way to end off the dark edges
that's a great cinematic way to do fairy
tales I'm not sure we've actually come
up with a better take on it yet there's
one person that's cracked how to do
fairy tales and that was Shelley Duvall
oh man all right let's go out with a
whimper just like these movies next week
is something that is just as forgettable
and of Em's worthy yes and hems unworthy
that's it for this week thanks for
sitting with it we do this together
we'll see you next time bye-bye
[Music]
you